[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم مشاهدينا الازهر بين برلمان
يستعد لتغيير القوانين المنظمه لعمله
وتعيين امامه او اقالته ووسائل اعلام
محسوبه على السلطه تطلق عليه سهام نقد
تحول الى تطاول في بعض الاحيان وسلطه
تركته فريسه لخصوم اليوم والامس وسط هذا
كله يجد الازهر نفسه في حصار غير مسبوق
ليس من غريب يسعى لانهاء دوره التاريخي
وانما من قريب سلم اليه امره لكن بعد فتره
من الصمت المريب الذي فسر بالضعف تاره او
بانتظار مرور العاصفه تاره اخرى خرج
الازهر عن صمته وحذر من ان العبث به هو
عبث بحاضر مصر
وتاريخها ما هي ابعاد الحمله ضد الازهر
والى اين تقود هذه المؤسسه نبحث عن اجابات
الملف والبدايه بتقرير لاحمد
جرار لم يعتصم الازهر بالصمت هذه المره
فالهجر التي يتعرض لها من قبل اطراف
اعلاميه وبرلمان محسوبه على الرئيس عبد
الفتاح السيسي منذ تفجير كنيستي طنطا
والاسكندريه الاسبوع الماضي تبدو وكانها
عازمه على تسديد ضربه قاضيه للمؤسسه
الدينيه العريقه ومكانتها في وجدان
المصريين الازهر الشريف
فشل في مواجهه
الارهاب فشل الخطاب
الديني ليس في مصر خطاب دينيا يواجه
الارهاب لذلك جاء رد هيئه كبار علماء
الازهر بعيدا عن دبلوماسيته المعتاده اذ
وصف الهجمه بانها عبث بتاريخ مصر وحاضرها
وخيانه لضمير الامه كلها وبانها تجاوزت
جدليه تحميله ظلما مسؤوليه التفجيرين
وتنامي ظاهره العنف العشوائي الى التجريح
بثوابت الاسلام والى الطعن الفج في التراث
الفكري الذي تقوم عليه مناهج الازهر
معتبرا انه من التدليس الفاضح وتزييف وعي
الناس وخيانه الموروث تشويه مناهج الاسار
واتهامها بانها تفرخ الارهابيين واتهم
بيان الهيئه من وصفهم باعداء الازهر
واعداء الاسلام بالتنكر لحقيقه ان مناهج
الازهر اليوم هي نفسها مناهج الامس التي
خرجت رواد النهضه المصريه ونهضه العالم
الاسلامي سجال يشي بان الازمه بين نظام
السيسي ومؤسسه الازهر ليست كسابقاتها
وبان الجفاء والازمه الصامته بين الطرفين
والمستمره منذ عده اشهر قد تتحول الى
معركه كسر عظم في ظل سعي النظام المحموم
الى تطويع المؤسسه الدينيه بالكامل ووضعها
تحت عباءته وبحسب ناشطين مصريين فان شيخ
الازهر احمد الطيب ورغم الدور الذي لعبه
في مشهد الانقلاب على اول رئيس مدني منتخب
في تاريخ مصر فانه يدفع اليوم ثمن عدم
تجاوبه مع دعوات السيسي المتكرره الى ما
يصف بثوره دينيه تعيد تجديد الخطاب الديني
وفق مقاساته فالرجل وان لم يكن يوما في صف
معارضي النظام لكنه يبدو حريصا على ان لا
يورط نفسه والمؤسسه التي يراسها في مشروع
فضفاض قد يمس ثوابت المجتمعي وهويته لا
سما في ظل عداء النظام المستحكم مع تيارات
الاسلام السياسي لذلك بات هدفا مفضلا لته
الاعلاميه التي تتقن شيطنه الخصوم وهي ذات
الاله التي تجاهلت بشكل كامل الاشاره الى
تقصير الجهاز الامني وعجزه عن منع الهجمات
الدمويه ووجدت في حادثه تفجير الكنيستين
الفرصه المناسبه لتصفيه الحساب مع مؤسسه
الازهر
ومناهجه ينضم الينا من اسطنبول الشيخ عصام
تليمه الداعيه الاسلامي واحد شيوخ الازهر
في الاستديو ينضم الينا الكاتب الصحفي
سليم عزوز ومن القاهره عبر خدمه سكايب
مجدي شندي رئيس تحرير جريده المشهد
الاسبوعيه ومعك نبدا سيد مجدي شندي لماذا
اطلق العنان لوسائل اعلام تدور في فلك
السلطه لتشن حمله بهذا الشكل على الازهر
ومشيخه الازهر
بالتحديد يعني هي مساله تحميل الازهر
الفشل الامني وا السياسي في مقاومه
الارهاب وا اجهاضه من جذوره والغاء البيئه
الحاضنه التي ا توفر ل الارهاب ان ينشا
وان يجند وان يستفحل هذا امر غير منطقي
وغير طبيعي الازهر هو ركن ركن رقيم في مصر
يلعب دورا اساسيا في تشكيل هويه مصر و
شخصيتها الوطنيه واذا ا يعني توجهت السهام
نحو الازهر الشريف فان هذا بالضبط ما
يريده تنظيم داعش وكل التنظيمات
الارهابيه لان الازهر كان يمثل عقبه سودا
في مواجهه افكار التطرف سيد مجدي الان
يعني العنوان المطروح ان الازهر لم يستطع
تجديد الخطاب الديني وبالتالي لم يستطع ان
يقف بمواجهه الارهاب وهي مسؤوليه
السلطه الامنيه كما تقول ولكن هل هذا هو
سبب بالتحديد ام ان هذا العنوان الذي
تختفي وراءه اسباب سلطويه
اخرى لا يعني اذا اذا تحدثنا عن الفشل في
تجديد الخطاب الديني هذا نوع من الافتراء
الافتراء على الواقع والافتراء ايضا على
التاريخ يعني شيوخ الازهر المجددين منذ
اكثر من
عاما يعني يمارسون التطوير حقيقه ان
يعني كتب التراث
والموروث الديني يحتاج الى اعاده تنقيه
يحتاج الى تجديد يحتاج الى اجتهادات جديده
لكن لا نستطيع ان نقول ان الازهر فشل في
تجديد الخطاب الديني لان هذا ليس دور
الازهر وحده يعني مطلوب ايضا بيئه حاضنه
للازهر تتيح له الفرصه لكي يفعل ذلك بحريه
و بشكل يعني طيب دعني هنا
انتقل السيد
مجدي دعني انتقل الى الشيخ عصام تليمه من
من جانبك يا شيخ عصام
كيف تقرا الان هذا المشهد مشهد الحمله
الاعلاميه المنظمه ضد مشيخه
الازهر لا شك هذه طبعا الحمله الاعلاميه
المنظمه هي اشبه بهروب من المسؤوليه
الامنيه لدوله العسكر حول القيام بواجبها
والا ما علاقه الازهر ومناهج الازهر
بالارهاب مناهج الازهر انتمى اليها
مستشرقون وغربيون تخرجوا منها في القرن
التاس والقرن العشرين مناهج الازر ازهر
هناك مفكرين اقباط قدامى ومعاصر تخرجوا
على هذد الازهر كل رواد النهضه التعليميه
والعلميه في العالم العربي والاسلامي
والمصري في العصر الحديث تبوا وتخرجوا على
المناهج الازهريه فنسبه المناهج الازهريه
والتطرف اليها كلام غير منطقي خاصه انه
الى الان لم يثبت ان ارهابيا واحدا نسب
الى الازهر يعني ثبت بتحقيق ان ارهابي او
فجر نفسه وقام بعمل ارهابي وادين ثبت انه
مر على اي دور من ادوار الازهر ولا حتى
الكتاتيب الازهريه فهي تهمه يراد بها عزف
الناس عن المسؤوليه الحقيقيه للاجهزه
الامنيه والقوات المسلحه في سيناء وفي
طنطا وفي الاسكندريه وفي كل ربوع مصر لقاء
المسؤوليه وعتق المسؤوليه على لكن اليس
هنا من مسؤوليه الازهر عفوا الشيخ عصام
لكن في المقابل اليس من مسؤوليه الازهر
العمل بشكل بشكل حثف وفعلي على تجذب
الافكار المتطرفه وتجديد هذا الخطاب
الديني وتهذيبه كي لا
يستغل من قبل المتطرفين اليست هذه ايضا
مسؤوليه
ازهريه كلام صحيح لكن من سيمكن الازهر من
هذا التجديد لان بدايات ان تمنع هذا
التطرف عليك ان تقيم العدل بين الناس هذا
اول شيء اذا ترك للا ظهر ان يجدد الخطاب
الديني اول مفرده من هذا التجديد تجديد
الخطاب الديني السياسي اول مفردات هذا
التجديد الا يحكم الناس احد الا من يختاره
الناس بالصندوق هذا الحاكم جاء بصندوق
الذخيره لا بصندوق الانتخابات لو الازهر
قال رايه معناه ان هذا الرجل سيحاكم معنى
من سفك الدماء سيحاكم هل يسمح لهذا
التجديد ان يقوم به الازهر كل من يرفع
رايه التجديد الان لا يدفع ضريبه التجديد
الذي يدفع ضريبه التجديد دي هم الذين
يعارضون هم الذين يسجنون في المعتقلات
يشردون من ينادي بالتجديد الان هو من يجلس
بجوار كرسي الحاكم يسبح بحمده ويلعق يده
ويستفيد بنعمته اللي بيدعي التجديد لانه
يعلم ان اولى مفردات التجديد ان يقوم
العدل بين الناس وحقوق الانسان طيب ا سيد
سليم عزوز ما الذي افسد العلاقه بين
النظام المصري
ومشيخه الازهر والمعروف ان مشيخه الازهر
كانت مع انقلاب 30 من يونيو وزير الداخليه
الذي اقاله ا عبد الفتاح السيسي محمد
ابراهيم كان مع الانقلاب وشاركه وشريك
اساسي في الانقلاب العسكري عبد الفتاح
السيسي يعني لا يريد احدا من شركائه الذين
كانوا معه حتى الوزراء الناصريين الذين
كانوا في حكومته تم الاستغناء عن خدماتهم
هو لا يريد احد جاء هو الى السلطه فوجده
في مكانه نحن شاهدنا كيف ان هشام جنينه
يعلن انه يتمنى ان يلتقي عبد الفتاح
السيسي ويطلب لقائه وفي المقابل عبد
الفتاح السيسي يقوم باقالته وتقديمه
للمحاكمه هذا رجل لا يريد لاحد شاركه في
الانقلاب ان يكون موجودا يريد ان يكون هو
صاحب السلطه في
اختيار القيادات العليا في الدوله في
المؤسسات المستقله على وجه التحديد هو
لديه يعني احد الشيوخ الصغار يريد ان وهو
اسامه الازهري يريد ان يصبه ع الفتاح
السيسي شيخا للازهر هذ الهجوم الاعلامي
على الشيخ احمد الطيب هو في واقع امر تم
بتعليمات لانه يعني ايه معناه انه تفجيرات
جرت في الكنيسه فيبقى الهجوم على شيخ
الازهر يعني هذه لاول مره ولاول مره تكون
هناك حمله بهذا الشكل على شيخ الاظهر ربما
حدث في عهد مبارك مقال واحد كتب الدكتور
فرج فوده في جرده الاهالي التي يصدرها حزب
التجمع حزب اليسار في مصر ضد الشيخ جاد
الحق على جاد الحق نتج عن ده ايه ان حسن
مبارك الشيخ جاد الحق التقى بحسني مبارك
وانه تم منع فرج فوده من الكتابه تماما في
في صحيفه الاهي بعد هذا المقال الحاصل
الان ان هناك عمليه ضغط من اجل ان يشعر
الشيخ الطيب بانه اهان او انه مهان او انه
اهين فيبادر بتقديم استقالته في منصب هو
في في النهايه محصن بحكم الدستور ام ومحصن
بحكم القانون وليس من سلطه عبد الفتاح
السيسي ان يقيل شيخ الازهر وبالتالي كل ما
يحدث هو تعليمات واظنها تعليمات مباشره
فتاح السيسي باعتبار انها هؤلاء الذين
يهاجمون الازهر الان هم الازر على
الاعلاميه لاح على كل على كل هناك محاوله
لتعديل قوانين الازهر بما يسمح باقالته
وتعيين بديل عنه اريد ان اسال السيد مجدي
شندي في هذه النقطه سيد مجدي هل يعقل انه
لمجرد الاختلاف في بعض القضايا مثلا مع
الازهر على سبيل المثال ما عرف بتوثيق
الطلاق الشفهي او توح حيد خطبه الجمعه
فضلا عن فكره تجديد الخطاب الديني عندما
يكون هناك بعض الاختلاف مع السلطه هل يعقل
ان يلجا مباشره الى العمل على تعديل
القوانين بحيث يسمح
باقاله شيخ
الازهر لا بالتاكيد هذا ليس منطقيا الازهر
مؤسسه عريقه في مصر وهي اهم من اي حاكم
واقدم من اي حاكم وستبقى ويذهب الحكام
لكن من يدعونا الى هذا التوجه هم اناس
يعني يسيرون في ركاب السلطه ربما هم لا
يعرفون حقيقه الدور التنويري والدور
التاريخي الذي قام به الازهر في مقاومه
الاحتلالات المتعاقبه التي عانت منها مصر
لا يعرفون دوره في حفظ الاسلام الوسطي
الاسلام المصري نقيا
سمحا بعيدا عن الغلو وبعيدا عن التفري فقط
فقط نقطه سيد مجدي اريد منك باختصار عفوا
اريد منك باختصار اذا كان تمويل الازهر
يتم عبر السلطه يعني هذه وجهه نظر مقابله
الا يعني
في يعني كنتيجه طبيعيه ان يكون الازهر الى
حد ما متماشيا مع طروحات هذه السلطه ما
دام التمويل من قبلها باختصار
شوف السلطه لا تملك شيئا حتى تمول شيئا
يعني التمويل للازهر وللقضاء يتم من قبل
الدوله المصريه
والازهر هو واحد من اهم مؤسسات الدوله
وسبق ان قلت انه من الاركان الاساسيه التي
تشكل الهويه المصريه لا يتصور احد ان يكون
الازهر طيعا في يد اي سلطه او ازهر يعني
غير موجود لان الازهر مثله مثل رامات
الجيزه ومثل الاثار الفرعونيه التي تفتخر
بها مصر ولا ي نعم انتقل الى الى الشيخ
عصام تليمه هل بامكان الازهر ان يواجه
خصوصا موضوع
التعديل اذا طرح في
البرلمان هو يملك ذلك اذا اراد شيخ الازهر
وهيئه كبار العلماء الوقوف يدا واحده ضد
هذا الامر وحدث هذا ايام الرئيس السادات
حينما اراد فرض قانون الاحوال الش صيه
والحط من شان الازهر فاعتكف في بيته وهدد
بعدم ولم يداوم في مشيخه الازهر فرضخ انور
السادات وردخ الجميع العسكر دائما يرضخ
اذا وجد مشيخه الازهر وعمائم الازهر تقف
صفا واحدا نواه صلبه امام هذا الموقف اذا
وقفوا هذه الوقفه يقينا لن يستطيع لمجلس
الشعب ولا غيره ان يفعل شيئا امام هذه
الوقفه لانه يخشى مساله ان الازهر اساسا
له اوقاف صادرتها الدوله من حق الازهر ان
ان يطالب بها ولا تكون ميزانيه الازهر من
الحكومه او غيره بل يكون هو مصدر اموال
للدوله وليس جزءا منها ا
اي سيد سليم
عزوز الى اي مدى يمكن ان تستفحل هذه
الازمه بين الازهر
والنظام المصري انا اعتقد ان الازهر كسب
المعركه الان كتبها بهذا البيان القوي
كتبها ببيانه السابق في مواجهه دعوه
السيسي فيما يختص ب الطلاق الشفهي كسبها
عندما لم يرضخ شيخ الازهر ويتقدم
باستقالته لكن اعتقد ان القصه لم تتم
فصولا عبد الفتاح السيسي سوف يستغل واقعه
اخرى من اجل ان يحرك ذراعه الاعلاميه في
اطار الهجوم على شيخ الازهر لسبب مهم جدا
عبد الفتاح السيسي الاعلام الغ الغربي
خدعه خدعه بفكره انه يعني مرت لوثر العصر
ومرت لوثر الاسلام وانه بعدما اطلق فكره
ال يعني تجديد الخطاب الديني صار مجتهد
مصر الاول وهو يتحدث على انه يعني سوف
يحدد لنا ديننا وانه المسؤول عن دين
المصريين هو يريد مؤسسه تريد ان تحول لهذه
العناوين المبهمه يعني لما يتكلم على
تجديد الخطاب الديني طب يعني ايه هو
الخطاب الديني عشان نجدده هو يريد ازهر
طيع يجعل منه الها او نصف اله او نبي او ش
طيب هذه فقط هذه النقطه اسالك شيخ عصام هل
تتوقع ان يرضخ الازهر او يواجه قلت انه
يستطيع ان يواجه لكن فعليا هل تتوقع له ان
يذهب بهذا
الخيار اعتقد سيواجه المواجهه النعمه ليست
المواجهه الصادمه الوقوف امام هذا الامر
واعتقد ان معظم هيئه كبار العلماء مع
مشيخه الازهر في هذا الامر لان الامر الان
اصبح كما بين البيان الهجوم بعد الازهر
على ثوابت الاسلام فهم يعلمون انهم السور
الذي في ما بعده ما لا يمكن ان يضحى به
فاعتقد سيقف امام هذا الامر عدد لا باس به
من اصحاب الكلمه القويه في مشيخه الازهر
شكرا لك الشيخ عصام تليمه الداعيه
الاسلامي واحد شيوخ الازهر حدثتنا من
اسطنبول واشكر من القاهره عبر خدمه سكايب
كان معنا مجدي شندي رئيس تحرير جريده
المشهد الاسبوعيه وفي الاستديو اشكرك
الكاتب الصحفي سليم عزوز